there's something actually much more
nefarious happening directly to your
kids and they're constantly going after
the children so this is wild this is
from the libs of Tik Tock Twitter
account uh and you know Libs of Tik Tok
she gets in a lot of trouble with all
the all the evil people Froot Loops
promotes free access to a digital
library on their serial boxes for kids
the library offers a range of books to
teach kids themes of equity diversity
and inclusion Kelloggs wants to
indoctrinate your children with
breakfast cereal stop giving them your
money instead shop at official Public
Square where you can find millions of
products from companies that you can be
sure to share your values check them out
here blah blah blah but look at these
images on the Froot Loops box um you can
see their digital library and what's
going on in their Digital Library it's a
free online library of equity diversity
and inclusion family Centric content
including books podcasts and more
created in Partnership blah blah
blah all of this all of this it is first
off you if you you are giving I have two
young children like they have had
basically no sugar they're eating
organic they're eating real foods these
kids are huge great happy and healthy
and I will never the idea of giving them
just a bowl of pure sugar you're just
giving them a bowl of sugar and die when
you put fruit loops and I get it I love
fro Loops when I was a kid right but
like there's a better way to parent but
they are trying to hack their brains in
two ways they want to hack their brains
get them get them hopped up on sugar
nothing nutrition in the first place and
then oh you're all hopped up on sugar
now go to our website where you can
learn that you're racist and then you
got this little 5-year-old who's hopped
up on sh go Mommy I'm
racist it's just
insane